monsieur Sam n'a pas dirigé la
facture interne de prélavage à l'université d'ici
là Shawn plein de fous ne
m'est pas attaché je regarde le plus ancien
anniversaire d'alani non il fera la sieste à Kyoto
ouais je peux vous couvrir hé à Swiffer  eh bien
dans le premier film, toutes les filles sont
des étudiants de première année et c'est une histoire à propos d'
elles rejoignant le groupe et allant aux championnats
américains pour a cappella
, puis au début du deuxième
film où comme nous avons déjà écrasé
la compétition américaine comme trois
des moments où comme une sorte de superstars
d'a cappella et mon personnage la grosse Amy
est malheureusement une partie importante de la
disgrâce du groupe et de notre
point culminant nous tombons au point le plus bas
et l'histoire du deuxième film est de savoir comment nous
essayons de récupérer notre dignité  et remonter notre
chemin en participant aux
championnats du monde qui est une compétition beaucoup plus grande et
beaucoup plus intense diffamatoire
n'éliminera pas Canasta avec un topless un
body shop
das sound machine come ova very day
Victor Matheso  n plat salé la bomba
certains Kasim wallah bombas co garnir en
option llamo de lune avantika Sifu
Kenya hé Bella était-ce une mini compétence /
buczek laisser un pauvre ours en peluche et
réquisitionner une nouvelle famille nouvelle la nudité
absolue milkha hé Bosco 0c Ponca cul
en nu pavo n'a jamais eu de  grand sourire
on y va on y va ouais bordoni oui voter
rockso graine de ricin lon chi minh SE ona
ona gunilla soo gyum moteur de jeu oh mec
je voulais réaliser un film euh
j'adore ce film sur des
femmes drôles intéressantes j'aime cette
histoire j'ai  j'adore le ton je veux dire je
voulais vraiment faire une comédie je voulais faire
un film drôle cela représente très bien
ma personnalité ce film
j'aime tous les numéros musicaux c'était un
grand défi de devoir les mettre tous
ensemble et je savais que nous  pourrait le rendre aussi
drôle et je savais que nous pouvions améliorer
les chiffres de performance et donc il s'agissait
vraiment de s'assurer qu'il avait toujours du
cœur et que vous vous
souciez vraiment de ces personnages et
je pense que nous d  id it
can tivo catoosa si parla competition
cos me soo viale mid hoop on the target
by Bobby ballet Lima OH baa baa baa KU
design even oh god a lee keebum encore une fois
vous entendez du propulseur koala vous êtes assis dans
le CCF australien ce sera vous connaissez l'unité
2  tbs tu es génial
leur exemple motivo por Tootsie fito
laboratoire pom-pom girl